hopefully you guys like our brand new uh
set we've got new cameras
um we just kind of like not new lights
got kind of upgraded
every single aspect yeah behind the
scenes as well
so hopefully it looks clearer to you uh
please don't stare at my paws because i
saw them on our new cameras i'm just
like this kind of makes me uncomfortable
yeah yeah but now now i understand why
like movie stars like wear makeup
do i have to start like [ __ ]
moisturizing and like taking
i already don't know i look in 4k
i do miss the 720p days webcam where
your face was just so blurred and smooth
oh my god see every [ __ ] pixel on
your face does dazaki
make you take care of your like skin
face i don't know
i do skincare routine now do you i do
now who got you into it
um well it's okay what happened was that
when i was doing
4k and i was doing streams people were
commenting on my skin a lot more
okay so it is the upgrade to 4k and then
yeah literally the upgrade to 4k [ __ ]
everyone's going to be commenting on our
skin now
i asked a friend i was like hey i know
you're you're really into skincare
obviously uh a girl
and uh they were uh i was like hey you
you know stuff right tell me which stuff
to use they were like say no more i've
got like 500 korean products
all right all right i'm like wait
there's like an order yeah and there's
like i have to do like six things
but yeah sometimes i forget but it's
really long i have to put like a face
mask on
and then i've used that for like 15
minutes take that off and then put like
three different lotions on yeah there's
a reason why i grow out a bit
is inside my pores i have really really
bad bags though and i think that's like
just
just very unlucky and i use like an
anti-bag serum and i swear it just makes
my hair
it makes my eyes just go like this bro
i'm like
i've got like really bad bags as well
it's genetic as well so
it's it's like sometimes i have a good
night's sleep great night sleep i go on
camera and be like
you're going are you getting enough
sleep what's going on there and i'm like
i'm
sorry i'm sorry mum dad why'd you have
to give me these jeans
the bags under the eyes is a symbol of
how hard the grind for youtube is
like that's that's what i told my
audience i'm like i'm on the grind bro
sleepless nights as you can see like
when i do have sleepless nights then i
look like a [ __ ] zombie and then
people are just like oh
this is a [ __ ] necromancer right here
but like even on my best days i still
have like really bad
bags so i i just imagine the people who
like connor you have bags like [ __ ] off
like you don't have bats yeah right
like you have the most perfect eyes do
you really want me to be perfect is that
i don't want to be perfect i don't know
i don't have to deal with that [ __ ] i'm
barely trying to keep my skincare
routine in check and
actually barely doing anything i don't
even know if it's doing anything
yeah that's what i i've tried doing a
skincare routine and i've i stuck on it
for a month and
i'll be honest didn't notice the
difference at all or
didn't feel too much of it maybe felt
like
a bit of a difference but i don't know
it feels like a placebo
i feel like there are a lot of
businesses made for our insecurities
you know what i mean like no [ __ ] and
so you know meline came to me yeah our
producer of you all know
and was like hey connor um do you want
to go to this like salon
that my friend owns in japan all right
where they like do skin care stuff
right and then so i have like i said
before i have hemophilia
so i can't have like anything internal
bleeding happen to me yeah generally i
think most people
don't want that too no no no that's
normal now
but i literally can't have anything that
even risks it yeah yeah and so this
one of the skincare things is like may
cause internal bleeding and i'm like
hold up what's skin care going on here
is internal bleeding
so what does something maybe cause
internal so the first time i was like
may cause organ failure but you'll look
great the first time i was like no no no
no i'm not doing that
and then afterwards they were like you
should try it it's not really that bad
it's just the whole medical thing of
vidmy you know yeah
i'm like all right fine [ __ ] it i i
guess you're right
yeah i did it so what it was is that
like it was like electrocution
like it was like plasma that's mainly my
lane laughs because she's like it's
wrong
basically it was called a plasma shower
which isn't very comforting that sounds
like
those horrible punk bands right so that
sounds like an old from a league of
legends characters or something like
that
it's literally like an electric rod or
something that touches your face
yeah like i think it like strips your
skin i don't really know what it's doing
but when it would touch me in certain
places my face is like
they [ __ ] twitch and i could just
literally like the struggle legs
experiences it's not like burning
and i was like what is this did you just
get tricked into doing electro shock
therapy
i think they burned my face and i paid
100 bucks for it
and then they did something else which
is like uh it was like a vacuum and like
fluid and it felt really [ __ ] weird
and it was like yeah
they were doing it on my face it was
going in my ear cavities
i'm like how much how how much is
skincare worth it like
at this point i was like i don't think
this however good my face looks i don't
think it's worth it like i used to have
horrible acne in high school so compared
to then
i'm taking this who didn't who didn't
have horrible acne in high school but i
had like mine was so bad that like did
you ever use like proactive
no like that's kind of it's like that
really famous like anti-action yeah yeah
yeah yeah
that like says that like if you have
acne just use that for like a month
yeah you'll be completely clear i did
use it didn't do [ __ ] yeah didn't do
[ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah yeah i was like i didn't
do [ __ ] so then my parents were like all
right i found a stronger option
and just tried the stronger options
nothing [ __ ] works so i had to go to
the dermatologist and literally take
drugs for it did it work
it worked i mean now my face is clear
now so i'm just like compared to that
i'll take these paws [ __ ] i had horrible
acne i just dealt with it
and then i was just like which means you
just don't oh you just let it happen
yeah i mean i also i think working at
mcdonald's didn't help
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah the deep fat
fryer i swear dude that that [ __ ] turned
my
like pepperoni face into like all like
giggles
mcdonald's kitchens are like 95 oil
humidity right it's like
that like kicked it into overdrive yeah
i think i don't know when it went but
early youtube you can see i had like
[ __ ] tons of spots right you weren't
that sporty when i met you though
no dude i mean when you watch this
episode go live i'm sure mood and found
a [ __ ] pic of
me looking like i don't know like a puss
[ __ ] machine i don't know
i don't think you were that's body when
i met you either i think when i was like
21 though
okay so i think by then it stopped
calming down yeah yeah um but yeah when
i was like 19
yeah i'm glad i started youtube after
all of my acne went away because god
i can't imagine because the thing about
that and i had acne because the thing
about skin
skincare routine you know i like because
we we bought we all
care about optimization and all that
kind of [ __ ] right there's just
something about going my entire life
having like taking
five minutes to get ready in the morning
and then adding a skincare routine on
top of that
and then you you like quadrupling that
time in the morning not even before
you had like an extra half an hour to an
hour sometimes per morning and i'm just
like
is it worth this time effort that i'm
putting into is it making a difference
i don't know that's the reason why i
wanted short hair for a long time
because i just like dude
it's like one wipe of the towel yeah
your hair's dry
like that [ __ ] feels so good when you
get a clean like a haircut and it's
quite short and you just whoosh
dry hair yeah i'm ready i mean that's
why i decided to get rid of like
really really long hair that i had the
beginner trash days because like some
mornings i wake up and i'm like why is
my hair still damp
your hair moisture should never be part
of your routine that you have to like
put in and be aware of because that's
when i know i need to get a haircut when
i start noticing that my hair's still
wet when i want to do something else and
i'm just like
well i guess it's time to get a haircut
because it's getting way too much effort
to like
gel and dry and that's why i have a huge
respect for anyone who has long hair
and has to like deal with that [ __ ] yeah
and i don't know how how long did you
have your long hair for
uh way too long i think i had it for
like six months
six months yeah like it probably went
down to like maybe around here yeah
i mean that was during the trash taste
days as well yeah
but uh yeah once i cut it i was like god
why did i ever have that hair it was
so it was so horrible to manage
especially because i had it in like the
summer as well
so it was just like a [ __ ] sauna on
my head and i [ __ ] hated it yeah
never again never again people miss it
people are like oh i want the jesus hair
back
yeah no you don't no you don't know it's
disgusting how did you guys
figure out kind of like when's the first
time you figured out what kind of
haircut you wanted because
i went through like my entire life as a
kid have you seen yours
yeah yeah yeah yeah i just i just kind
of like didn't know i
obviously put up the picture i didn't
know how to take care of my hair
is it obvious is it obvious what the
[ __ ] did you style that [ __ ]
it was you know what i the reason i
styled my hair like this
is because it was the hairstyle that
took the least amount of effort to style
[ __ ] off
because when my hair was that short like
my hair's just my hair just like
naturally
spikes up when it's short so all i need
to do is get a bit of gel put it in
and it's done
that's the side of the gel mixture if
you did like you'd have blown up way
earlier if you did a how gear stylist
had videos
like i'm saying like you'd have blown up
like a year ago how to get a sasuke here
in 30 seconds okay it would have been
worth it my hair doesn't exist yeah
it would have been worth it because it
would have been a one minute video
exactly
couldn't get the ten minutes step two
you could have a
10 million view short right now if you
did that upload it to gigaforeign maybe
maybe i'll make a tick tock
youtube short youtube